[Musique]
paul emile victor vous faites partie de
la formation pour la sauvegarde de la
nature où en est le délégué général dans
un papier intitulé demain il sera trop
tard
vous parlez de la pollution de
l'antarctique mais en quoi cela nous
concerne-t-il nous parisiens par exemple
oui il est bien évident que c'est une
question que vous pouvez vous poser vous
pouvez aussi vous dire après tout si
tokyo est polluée au point que le
gouvernement japonais est obligé
d'intervenir pour interdire de manger du
poisson en trop grande quantité à cause
de la maladie
une manne de minamata vous avez entendu
parler de sas toutes choses atroces
cause du mercure dans les poissons les
parisiens peuvent se dire en quoi ça
nous concerne est évident la question
que vous posez et en particulier sur les
régions polaires et si j'ai parlé de la
pollution dans l'antarctique comme de la
pollution sur la calotte glaciaire du
groenland qui sont en dur de toutes les
régions
normalement polluer ou en tout cas où la
pollution locale n'existe pas c'est tout
simplement parce que je désire montrer
avec cela que les problèmes de la
pollution
depuis tous les problèmes qui vont
ensemble quand on parle la pollution
c'est un problème beaucoup plus large
mais cette même celui qui autour duquel
se cristallise la pensée actuellement et
même l'action c'est pour montrer que les
problèmes de pollution sont planétaires
et justement pas seulement parisien en
quoi ça intéresse les parisiens
simplement par le fait que le problème
de la pollution mais ton de l'atmosphère
au dessus de paris peut être localement
partiellement résolu en faisant un
effort énorme exactement ce qu'ont fait
les anglais par exemple à londres mais
que le problème d'un semble dont nous
souffrons à paris aussi bien que
n'importe où à romorantin ou n'importe
où ailleurs ne peut pas se résoudre
autrement que si tout le monde
quand je dis tout le monde je veux dire
tout le monde le globe
tous les habitants du monde ne s'y
mettent et ça c'est extrêmement
important à comprendre c'est à dire
qu'en réalité faut que chacun d'entre
nous soit se sentent concernées par le
problème et pas seulement informé est
actuellement en france on est informé du
problème on en est à peine conscient
dans l'ensemble de la population
il y en a extrêmement peu qu'ils se
sentent concernés or nous sommes tous
directement concernés
plus exactement soit directement
si on n'est pas encore trop vieux soit
est directement par les enfants que nous
avons car ce qui risque d'arriver et à
mon avis ce qui risque d'arriver ce qui
est bien pire que le voir la race
humaine disparaître quand on parle avec
les après des catastrophes effrayante ça
veut pas revenir sur ces problèmes de
catastrophes y en a d'autres qui en
parler mieux que moi ce qui est pire
c'est que la race humaine le dise
piratera peut-être pas elle s'adaptera
et s'adaptant elle risque de perdre ses
qualités d'homme
elles nous trouverons tout à fait
naturel de vivre dans des blockhaus est
d'enseigner à nos enfants dans les
blocos avec de l'ére artificielle est
d'enseigner à nos enfants ce qui était
un papillon ce qui était une fleur parce
qu'il y en aura plus que nous enseignons
aujourd'hui à nos enfants ce qui était
un diplodocus et nous trouvons également
tout à fait naturel pour sortir dans la
rue aussi naturel qu'aujourd'hui ça nous
paraît naturel de mettre une cravate on
n'est pas maintenant quand je sors je
m'éclate
et bien tout aussi naturel de mettre un
masque pour sortir dans la rue bien pour
lutter contre cet avenir que vous voyez
avec beaucoup de pessimisme il faut bien
le dire parler de création de commandos
entre guillemets qu'est ce que vous
entendez par commando je vois cet avenir
avec pessimisme mais je suis un
optimiste c'est à dire que je pense
qu'il n'est pas trop tard pour agir vous
donner quand même une limite à 25 ans
qui est pour beaucoup
voilà on n'a pas beaucoup de temps il
faut que chacun d'entre nous nous
agissions ce que veut dire pas
recommandée au cse si le seul à mon avis
je suis pas le seul d'ailleurs à penser
ça le seul danger réel que cours
l'espèce humaine aujourd'hui c'est pas
la bombe atomique c'est pas la guerre
atomique
ça c'est une rideau de fumée
car en définitive pour la guerre
atomique
il faut encore quelqu'un pour appuyer
sur le bouton ça se produira peut-être
pas tandis que
les problèmes qui vont se poser d'ici 25
ans avec beaucoup d'optimisme un peu
moins deux générations un peu plus je
veux dire deux générations ces problèmes
là il est certain qu'ils se poseront à
l'espèce humaine
c'est une certitude et c'est pourquoi
c'est le seul problème le problème
numéro 1 le seul véritable problème qui
se pose à la race humaine
il faut donc se battre contre ce
problème et c'est pourquoi je dis c'est
une véritable guerre qu'il faut mener
contre les problèmes de pollution et
tout ce qui va avec
et enfin en conclusion vous dit chacun
doit agir dans sa propre sphère avec les
moyens dont il dispose
quels sont les moyens que chacun d'entre
vous que vous que moi avons alors c'est
très simple à mon avis ça se situe sur
deux plans un plan individuel et local
et un plan général le plan individuel et
locales c'est une certaine discipline
personnelle et la participation corps
dont chaque ville dans chaque village il
ya des bonnes volontés étaient
quelquefois il ya des groupes organisés
la participation à ce que j'ai appelé
donc les commandos c'est à dire à des
groupes qui agissent pour nettoyer un
lac pour et why et une rivière pour
protester auprès d'un maire qui et c'est
au contraire pour aider replanter les
arbres ça c'est sur le plan personnel et
locales individuel le plan personnel et
général pour moi c'est ceci les
gouvernements n'agissent que sous
l'effet des opinions publiques
il faut donc qu'il se crée une opinion
publique s'est fait aux états unis dans
ce domaine qui se crée une opinion
publique pas selon françois peu partout
mais il faut commencer chez nous cette
opinion publique c'est vous c'est vous
c'est moi
donc là nous pouvons agir sert chacun
dans notre petit cercle
une fois que nous sommes convaincus
j'espère que la plupart des gens sur un
jour convaincu et se sentiront concernés
eh bien ils font parler pour que
d'autres soient convaincus est concernée
pour qu'il y ait une opinion publique et
sous l'effet d'une opinion publique
on remue des montagnes
[Musique]